je vais te ramener à la maison suis-moi
[Musique]
il crève les uns après les autres
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose pour
reconnaître
et en dehors de ça je prends toujours
rien si c'est ce que tu veux dire
[Musique]
bienvenue dans notre famille
la même chose que
et suspecté du meurtre d'Elvis kinkate
un dealer d'héroïne de la région
si vous le trouvez dites-lui que je veux
lui parler c'est tout
[Musique]
il t'a pas flyer c'est que tu as dû
parler tu lui as dit quoi
[Musique]
pour qui tu parles sans pareil
et Dieu approuverai ce que tu fais
et c'est pas Dieu qui m'a poussé à
accomplir son œuvre je sais pas qui
c'est
encore quelques péchés à accomplir mon
temps